ds fellows caelers this is then minute
peppers whipcar rhinoceros ishare hold on
to their papers back as there is an
exclusive look at toon euro network
with a relation paper that game of the
collaboration between google and the
carnegie mellon university
de peper is as fresh as it  gets because
this is the first time i have been given
and exclusive like before the paper came
out and this means that this video en de
papers himself with the place at the
same time this is really cool
and it's quite a no thank you very much
neural  network survival learning at
toughest door superuse follow for tests
that her difficult 3th place but
easy to demonstrate for instance it is
hard to meet a magical idea of what's
traffic sign first what who has plenty
of photographer software kind of idea is
simple we label a bunch  or photographer with
and die channel deda this 6 this is de
traffic sign and this one is een en free
this to learning garrett him
as a result the role at work should be
able to perform traffic sign detection
and the superhuman level for way fast
scientist' and google it might have
also shown as the this peak of by a
neural network wit reinforcement
learning we can get it to look after
screen and play computer games on a very
high level
it is incredible to see problems that
seems impossible for many decades
crumble one by one in quick succession
over the last few years
however we have problem and that
problem is interprata billet i dunno
drops the disney rollator star efficient
however they cannot explain their
decisions  to was at least not i no way
that weekend in their part 2 libya this
early works tried to visualize the
network probe level of meer hans
particularly wat chance of inputs make
this individual joran's extreme
lakeside het this paper
izeboud combining previously known techniques to
unlock more  careful with to visualize
the networks for instance week and
combined the individual you're on the go
live act  ion with glass attributions
this offer their way of understanding
how and your network decide whether a
photo
de pixel avatar of a tiger cat hier
lucas see which part of the
meer activate the van johan en wat
doen johannes looking for
fila wizy de final decision and storage
class so in it should be long to
de nek socialization en techni-show
zwitsal of dit actors contributed to
the final decision and how much they
can't read and takes a clip
and other way towards better interprata
buttocks die is through the crisis die oh
heating number of your hands' into
smaller groups witmarsum en tik opinion
this process is referred to as factory
section or you run group inc in de peper
has me do is we go it a horny
descriptive labels dat week en en drop
we intuitive mini's
for instance  here we see that in order
for the network to classify the email and
they labrador
het nice to see a combination of flappie irises
do the forehead the game off and a band
driver and  week and or socks later
inactivation with the show which part of
the edge lakeside group sex ipad please
note that again foils cars the service
this is beautiful peper and this has us
or in the morning already many balk i said clean
from this moment with plenty of
interactive I symposia come play with
not only act with the code is open source
sorry hear if she labels reproduce the
specialization coat with little to no
sorrow mix order counter in the video
discription so much and for your
generous support na see you next time
[  Music]